you
[Applause]
this is me at five years old
shortly before jumping into this
beautifully still pool of water I soon
find out the hard way that this pool is
completely empty because the ice-cold
water is near freezing and literally
takes my breath away even though I
already know how to swim I can't get up
to the water's surface no matter how
hard I try that's the last thing I
remember trying to do before blacking
out
turns out the lifeguard on duty had been
chatting with two girls when I jumped in
and I was soon underwater so he couldn't
actually see or hear me struggle I was
eventually saved by a girl walking near
the pool who happened to look down and
see me the next thing I know I'm getting
melts mouth and being rushed to the
hospital to determine the extent of my
brain loss if I had been flailing at the
water's surface
the lifeguard would have noticed and
come to save me I share this near-death
experience because it illustrates how
dangerous things are when they're just
beneath the surface today I study
implicit gender bias and startups which
I consider to be far more insidious than
mere overt bias for this very same
reason when we see or hear an investor
behaving inappropriately towards an
entrepreneur we're aware of the problem
and at least have a chance to do
something about it
but what if there are subtle differences
in the interactions between investors
and entrepreneurs that can affect their
outcomes differences that we're not
conscious of that we can't directly see
or hear before studying startups at
Columbia Business School I spent five
years running and raising money from my
own startup I remember constantly racing
around to meet with prospective
investors while trying to manage my
actual business at one point I joked
that I had reluctantly pitched each and
every family member friends colleague
angel investor and VC
this side of the Mississippi well in the
process of speaking to all these
investors I noticed something
interesting was happening I was getting
asked a very different set of questions
than my male co-founder I got asked just
about everything that could go wrong
with the venture to induce investor
losses while my male co-founder was
asked about our Ventures homerun
potential to maximize investor gains
essentially everything that could go
right with a venture he that asked how
many new customers we were going to
bring on well I got asked how we were
gonna hang on to the ones we already had
well as the CEO of the company I found
this to be rather odd in fact I felt
like I was taking crazy pills but I
eventually rationalized it by thinking
maybe this has to do with how I'm
presenting myself or it's something
simply unique to my startup well years
later I made the difficult decision to
leave my startup so I could pursue a
lifelong dream of getting my PhD is that
Columbia that I learned about a social
psychological theory originated by
professor Tori Higgins called regulatory
focus which differentiates between two
distinct motivational orientations of
promotion and prevention a promotion
focus is concerned with gains and
emphasizes hopes accomplishments and
advancement needs while a prevention
focus is concerned with losses and
emphasizes safety responsibility and
security needs
since the best case scenario for
prevention focus is to simply maintain
the status quo this has us treading
water just to stay afloat while
promotion folks focus instead has a
swimming in the right direction it's
just a matter of how far we can advance
why had my very own Eureka moment when
it dawned on me that this concept of
promotion sounded a lot like the
questions posed to my male co-founder
while prevention resembled those
questions asked of me as an
entrepreneurship scholar I started
digging into the research on startup
financing and discovered there's an
enormous gap between the amount of funds
that male and female founders raised
although women found 30
percent of US companies they only get 2%
of the venture funding I got to thinking
what if this funding gap is not due to
any fundamental difference in the
businesses started by men and women what
if women get less funding than men due
to a simple difference in the questions
that they get asked after all when it
comes to venture funding entrepreneurs
need to convince investors of their
startups homerun potential it's not
enough to merely demonstrate you're not
going to lose your investors money so it
makes sense that women would be getting
less funding than men if they're
engaging in prevention as opposed to
promotion oriented dialogues why got the
chance to test this hypothesis on
companies with similar quality and
funding needs across all years that the
funding competition known as TechCrunch
Disrupt startup battlefield has run in
New York City since its inception in
2010 TechCrunch is widely regarded as
the ideal place for startups launch with
participants including startups that
have since become household names like
Dropbox Fitbit and mint presenting to
some of the world's most prominent VCS
will despite the comparability of
companies in my sample mail that
startups went on to raise five times as
much funding as a female at once this
made me especially curious to see what's
driving this gender disparity well took
a while but I got my hands on all the
videos of both the pitches and the Q&A
sessions from TechCrunch and I had them
transcribed I first analyzed the
transcripts by loading a dictionary of
regulatory focused terms into the
linguistic inquiry and word count
software called Luke this Luke software
generated the frequencies of promotion
and Prevention words in the transcribed
text as a second method I had each of
the questions and answers manually coded
by the Tori Higgins research lab at
Columbia regardless of the topic at hand
an intention can be framed in promotion
or prevention let's take that top
of customers I mentioned briefly earlier
a promotion coded question sounds like
how many new customers do you plan to
acquire this year well a prevention
coded one sounds like how do you plan to
retain your existing customers during
the same time I also gathered background
information on the startups and
entrepreneurs that can affect their
funding outcomes like the startups age
quality and funding needs and the
entrepreneurs past experience so I could
use these data points as controls in my
analysis well the very first thing that
I found is that there's no difference in
the way entrepreneurs present their
companies in other words both male and
female entrepreneurs use similar degrees
of promotion and prevention language in
their actual pitches so having ruled out
this difference on the entrepreneur side
I then moved on to the investor side
analyzing the six minutes of Q&A
sessions that entrepreneurs engaged in
with the VCS after pitching when
examining the nearly 2000 questions and
corresponding answers in these exchanges
both of my methods showed significant
support for the fact that male
entrepreneurs get asked promotion
questions and female entrepreneurs get
asked prevention questions in fact a
whopping 67% of the questions posed to
male entrepreneurs for promotion focused
while 66% of those posed to female
entrepreneurs were prevention focused
what's especially interesting is that I
expected female VCS
to behave similarly to male VCS given
its prevalence in the popular media and
the venture funding literature I
expected the birds of a feather theory
of homophily to hold here
meaning that male VCS would favor male
entrepreneurs with promotion questions
and female VCS would do the same for
female entrepreneurs but instead all
VC's displayed the same implicit gender
bias manifested in the regulatory focus
of the questions they posed to male
versus female candidates so female bees
these asked male entrepreneurs promotion
questions and then turned around and
asked female entrepreneurs prevention
questions just like the male visas did
so given the facts that both male and
female VCS are displaying this implicit
gender bias what effect if any does this
have on startup funding outcomes my
research shows it has a significant
effect the regulatory focus of investor
questions not only predicted how well
the startups would perform at the
TechCrunch Disrupt competitions but also
how much funding the startups went on to
raise in the open market
those startups who are asked for
dominantly promotion questions went on
to raise seven times as much funding as
those asked for venturing questions but
I didn't stop there I then moved on to
analyze entrepreneurs responses to those
questions and I found that entrepreneurs
are apt to respond in kind to the
questions they get meaning a promotion
question B gets a promotion response and
a prevention question B gets a
prevention response now this might make
intuitive sense to all of us here but it
has some unfortunate consequences in
this context of venture funding so what
ends up happening is that a male
entrepreneur gets asked a promotion
question granting him the luxury to
reinforce his association with the
favorable domain of gains by responding
in kind while a female entrepreneur gets
asked a prevention question and
inadvertently aggravates her association
with the unfavorable domain of losses by
doing so these responses then trigger
venture capitalists subsequent bias
questions and the questions and answers
collectively fuel a cycle of bias that
merely perpetuates the gender disparity
pretty depressing stuff right well
fortunately there's a silver lining to
my findings those plucky entrepreneurs
who managed to switch focus by
responding to prevention questions with
promotion answers went on to raise 14
times more funding than those who
responded to prevention questions with
prevention answers so what this means
is that if you're asked a question about
defending your startups market share
you'd be better served to frame your
response around the size and growth
potential of the overall pie as opposed
to how you merely plan to protect your
sliver of that pie so if I could ask
this question I would say we're playing
in such a large and fast-growing market
that's bound to attract new entrants we
plan to take increasing share in this
market by leveraging our startups unique
assets
I've thus subtly redirected this
dialogue into the favorable domain of
gains now these results are quite
compelling among startups that launched
at TechCrunch
but field data can merely tell us that
there's a correlational relationship
between regulatory focus and funding so
I sought to see whether this difference
in regulatory focus can actually cause
funding outcomes by running a controlled
experiment on both angel investors and
ordinary people simulating the
TechCrunch Disrupt environment i had
participants listen to four six-minute
audio files of ten question-and-answer
exchanges that were manipulated for
promotion and prevention language and
then ask them to allocate a sum of
funding to each venture as they saw fit
well my experimental results reinforced
my findings from the field those
scenarios where entrepreneurs were asked
promotion questions received twice the
funding allocations of those where
entrepreneurs were asked prevention
questions what's especially promising is
the fact that those scenarios for
entrepreneurs switched as opposed to
match focus when they received
prevention questions received
significantly more funding from both
sets of participants so to my female
entrepreneurs out there here are a
couple simple things you could do the
first is to recognize the question
you're being asked are you getting a
prevention question if this is the case
answer the question at hand by all means
but merely frame your response in
promotion and effort to garner higher
amounts of funding for your startups the
unfortunate reality though is that both
men and women evaluate
startups display the same implicit
gender bias in their questioning
inadvertently favoring male
entrepreneurs over female ones so do my
investors out there I would offer that
you have an opportunity here to approach
Q&A sessions more even-handedly not just
so that you could do the right thing but
so that you can improve the quality of
your decision making by flashing the
same light on every startups potential
for gains and losses you enable all
deserving startups to shine and you
maximize returns in the process today I
get to be that girl walking by the pool
sounding the alarm that something is
going on beneath the surface together we
have the power to break this cycle of
implicit gender bias and startup funding
let's give the most promising startups
regardless of whether they're led by men
or women a fighting chance to grow and
thrive thank you
[Applause]
[Music]